sunburned seagulls knife-wielding crabs
three very good reasons to spend
absolutely no time outside this summer
thankfully there are at least 17 more
excellent reasons to cancel your beach
plans this year 18 if you count the fact
that you'll definitely get sand in your
bathing suit area December of 2017 has
some must-sees for anybody's list so
butter up your popcorn and let's get
your butt meats in the theater seats for
these blockbuster films pirate to the
caribbean dead men tell no tales we're
four films deep into the Pirates of the
Caribbean franchise and Johnny Depp's
Captain Jack Sparrow is still
swashbuckling his way across the seven
seas the newest installment dead men
tell no tales
we'll bring us one film deeper this time
the race is on to find the Trident of
Poseidon which gives its owner complete
power over the seas the notoriously
creepy Javier Bardem appears as Jack's
undead nemesis and franchise favorites
Orlando Bloom and Geoffrey Rush are
making a return to the series once more
also watch out for a cameo by Paul
McCartney in his second weirdest
nautical film role when the film is
released on may 26th they watch let's be
totally honest no one ever watched
Baywatch in the 90s for its stimulating
plot now it was mostly for the totally
wicked Hulk Hogan jetski accidents
[Applause]
now the TV hit best known for its red
swimsuit some slow-motion running is
back this time is a big-screen comedy
hey it worked for 21 Jump Street right
yeah starring Dwayne the rock Johnson
and Zac Efron is lifeguards who have to
stop a criminal mastermind
and with cameos by original Baywatch
stars Pamela Anderson and David
Hasselhoff this film looks like a pretty
good way to start your summer hit the
beach on May 26th Wonder Woman on June
2nd Wonder Woman finally gets a film of
her own and it only took like 76 years
seriously how many Batman and Superman
movies do we need before a lady finally
gets a break a far cry from the spinning
Wonder Woman of the 70s gelded Oats
turned as the superhero has already
proven that she can kick some butt and
use her lasso like a boss now her solo
film explores her Amazonian origins and
life during World War one Plus Chris
Pine has a history of making new
franchises great so his place in the
cast is a great sign The Mummy welcome
to the universal cinematic universe the
Universal universe the cinematic
Universal actually we're not totally
sure what they're calling it yet On June
9th Universal is getting into the
universe building game creating a
coherent collection of movies from its
classic monsters beginning with the
mummy Frankenstein's monster The
Invisible Man The Creature from the
Black Lagoon and probably a Dracula or
two will eventually come together to do
whatever it is this monsters do and it
all starts this summer Tom Cruise is a
fantastic choice to lead a new action
universe and this film will feature the
first character crossover with Russell
Crowe playing dr. Jekyll signaling a
whole monstrous world to come hopefully
this song will play over the end credits
of every one of these movies
wages among cars three when the first
teaser for Pixar's Cars three basically
featured hero Lightning McQueen getting
slow-motion murdered by an accident on
the track you know you're in for a very
weird ride the Cars franchise is getting
into some pretty unexpected stuff
especially considering cars too focused
on mater becoming a spy who could
possibly be prepared for the dark
intensity of cars three not the hundreds
of crying children who just saw their
hero's body parts flying in every
direction the film deals with Lightning
McQueen getting aged out of his port and
trying to win back a claim from the
younger faster cars which sounds like
some pretty heavy stuff the original
voice cast returns on June 16th
alongside army hammer
Nathan Fillion and Kerry Washington get
ready to feel old transformers the last
night when you hear Michael Bay you
think one thing explosion on the 10th
anniversary of the start of Michael
Bay's Transformers franchise we get his
fifth installment about shape-changing
alien robots don't take the last in the
last night too literally though they
said it may be his last film but
paramount is definitely making a
bumblebee movie and will probably crank
out more transformers as long as the box
office receipts keep rolling in and the
action figures keep selling in the last
night Optimus Prime isn't exactly around
and it's up to CUNY humans Mark Wahlberg
Anthony Hopkins and Stanley Tucci to
save the world from evil BOTS
the film won't suffer from any shortage
of action and explosions because you
know Michael Bay hi I'm Michael Bay
director of Hollywood hits such as
transformers and I demand things
awesome awesome pussycat awesome
barbecue oh-ho
and there's even a badass girl fighter
if you didn't get enough of that in
Logan transform and roll out on June
23rd baby driver director Edgar Wright
described his newest film baby driver as
a car movie
fueled by music it looks like a huge
departure from his usual fare which
includes Jonathan ed Hot Fuzz and Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world starring Ansel
Elgort Kevin Spacey
Jamie Foxx and Jon Hamm baby driver
crashes into theaters on June 28 just a
few weeks ahead of schedule Despicable
Me 3 we get double the Steve Carell and
despicable knees latest sequel when GRU
finds his long-lost long-haired
twin brother Drew who convinces him to
return to his evil ways for just one
last heist and as always there's going
to be plenty of minions because that
never gets old never for real prepare
for a whole new wave of terrible minion
memes from your troubled aunt Gloria on
Facebook in this third installment
cartoon mayhem is pretty much guaranteed
Kristen Wiig returns joined by Jenny
slate and Trey Parker making a rare non
South Park voice appearance prepare for
super villainy on June 30th
Steve Carell hasn't had such an
entertaining twin since prison Mike the
worst thing about prison was good was
the Dementors thing flying all over the
place and they were scary and then they
come down and he sucked the soul out of
your body and in height
spider-man homecoming we may be on to
our third version of spider-man since
2002 but we're excited to see how Tom
Holland handled his own picture after
his Peter Parker stole the show in
Captain America Civil War so far Holland
has given the character his own spin
while remaining true to the Spidey that
we all know and love with Robert Downey
jr. crossing over as Tony Stark and
Michael Keaton as the vulture
we can't wait to witness spider-man 3.0
on July 7th
war for the Planet of the Apes monkeys
and humans had been at war for hundreds
of years but this time it's serious
Caesar rides again in war for the Planet
of the Apes on July 14th and now he's on
a quest for vengeance woody harrelson
stars is the vicious kernel the leader
of the human army and director Matt
Reeves returns to the helm once again
though it might seem that this war would
conclude the Planet of the Apes story
Reeves and producer Dylan Clark say
there will be room for plenty more Apes
stories to come hopefully at least one
of them will be a musical I hate every
icy from Jim Panay to chimpanzee Dunkirk
it's true there's at least one big film
this summer that is in a remake reboot
or sequel okay yes there was a movie
called Dunkirk in 1958 but this summer's
version is all-new and comes from an
original script by Christopher Nolan
who's taking a break from sci-fi fantasy
fair Nolan will also direct with Dark
Knight alums Tom Hardy and Killian
Murphy starring as well as Kenneth
Branagh and Mark Rylance it's the true
tale of a difficult evacuation of Allied
soldiers from the beaches of Dunkirk
France this historical action drama
filmed on-location seems like a great
palate cleanser from the rest of
summer's fantasy fair you know if you
like to cleanse your palate with the
horrors of war check it out on July 21st
valerian and the city of a thousand
planets Luc Besson the guy who gifted
the world with Milla Jovovich and
thermal bandages in the fifth element is
here to bring us another Future set
action adventure based on the French
sci-fi comic series valerian and Laura
lein the film is about a peaceful
civilization threatened with a great
evil time-traveling special ops heroes
valerian and Laura Lee and are there to
stop it world building ingenious aliens
and shape-shifting Rihanna yes this
movie has it all Bethan knows how to
make futuristic sci-fi and valerian
seems to be no exception get ready to
save the universe on July 21st the emoji
movie is my pleasure to announce
first movie yay
sure making a film based on instant
messaging symbols may sound odd but with
a pretty solid voice cast director Tony
Leone this has figured out a way to make
it work
probably legendary comedian Steven
Wright who has always been the living
breathing man emoji is just one of the
many inspired castings plus I stayed up
all night playing poker with tarot cards
got a full house and four people died
other emojis include TJ Miller Jennifer
Coolidge Ilana Glazer Maya Rudolph and
James Corden oh and don't forget Patrick
Stewart playing the illustrious role of
poop honestly that's enough reason to
see this thing on opening day July 28th
the Dark Tower this eagerly anticipated
adaptation slash continuation of the
Stephen King book series stars Idris
Elba as the gunslinger Matthew
McConaughey is a man in black our Jenna
means battling through an Old West
dystopia not exactly following the books
The Dark Tower sees the gunslinger
searching for well the Dark Tower in
order to give life back to his land
after a delay to complete the film's
visual effects the Dark Tower will be
premiering on August 4th
Anabelle creation she's the creepiest
doll since Chucky and whatever this
thing is this summer Annabelle is back
to haunt your dreams and now we get to
meet Annabelle's makers who are probably
totally nice people of course all of the
fun starts after they take in a nun and
a group of children after their
orphanage closes down surely nothing bad
will happen to them in a summer with
very few horror films make sure to check
out this sequel on August 11th to get
your fright fix the hit man's body guard
it's a tale as old as time the best body
guard in the world has to keep a hitman
safe so he can testify at the
International Court of Justice they also
have to bring down a murderous dictator
and somehow try to get along so like the
original odd
ryan reynolds gary oldman and samuel
l.jackson make this international
intrigue action film look like a late
summer winter don't get wacked until at
least August 18th if you want to check
this one out Polaroid Norwegian director
Lars clef Berg builds upon his 2015
short film of the same name with
Polaroid which promises to creep your
pants off on August 25th
starring Riverdale's Madeleine pêche
finding Carter's Kathryn Prescott and
x-files alum Mitch be leggy the story
centers on an outcast teen who finds
advantage Polaroid camera with some kind
of terrible curse since all the people
who get their pictures taken come to a
horrible end if it's anything like the
original short you'll never want to say
cheese again I thought I could be a
matching hero thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]